well you may remember watching Celine
perform on The Voice a few years back
and the list of superstars who have been
on that show to sing and mentor is
amazing and just when you think that
they can't possibly get any bigger well
it becomes divine you ready
okay I'm gonna brag on you here I begged
for Bette Midler to be my mentor because
I please I mean she's my favorite people
ever
why don't you unbutton one of your
shirts that's a better look that's a
better look yeah I will not flash my man
boobs all the time for the girls my word
whoever thought you'd see the divine
Miss M teaming up with Blake he's fun
he's cute he's whip-it he's funny he's
witty he sings great plays great guitar
sold millions of records I mean let's go
for 10 well I Bryce his own song he's
gonna give me one okay I wish Wow we so
want to see these two hit the road
together and did you notice the pink
streaks in BET's hair seemed she was
going a little bit for the Gwen Stefani
by oh you're so darling let me braid
your beard I can't think of anybody who
knows more about the entertainment
industry than Bette I thought you were
gonna say you wanted me because I swear
tonight all the voice coaches are
partnering up with star guest mentors
for their teams battle rounds Sammy
Hagar is with Adam Levine and the new
daddy is over moon with new daughter
Dusty Rhodes
so say can you imagine Adam Levine being
your father he let me know Adams team
includes a Billy Gillman the former
child country star
Billy you're so good and you can do so
much but sometimes you try to do all of
it
Miley is paired with a legendary rocker
Joan Jett this is crazy
this isn't even a battle anymore this is
repairing this is they're going on tour
I'm opening an Alicia Keys is what you
with Charlie puth I mean I'm just trying
to be like you I grow up Wow yeah and
part of the reason the coaches and
mentors work so well together it's
because they're fans of each other and
friends and I are gonna go into
businesses together and then we're gonna
sit on the beach and and work when we
want yes which is never